bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo tornati
seppi non fatemi domande se sono
conciato così perché nel blog avevo
detto che avrei fatto vito di è più così
e quindi dover assolutamente farlo
iniziamo perché vedo già i nomi
bellissimi tipo di bacio tra level
partiamo con lo scià nuovamente level
perché non partiamo un cazzo la partenza
con la elle che casca e già è già
bellissimo complimento
ok questo sapevo questo lo sapevo non
puoi fregare l'uomo coi baffi
ok come non detto cazzo perfetto ci sia
calmi non sto capendo una sega è in
genere dove pericoloso ovviamente tanto
non sarà pericoloso infatti lo sa bene
mai trovato una seria ma cosa mi dice
questo traguardo non è un traguardo ma
proprio non me lo sarei mai aspettato
giuro ha veramente incredibile tratto
luca più che è morto a caso perché fra
tutte le cose che si potranno esplodere
gli è esploso solo il culo
non lo so ok stavolta penso mi stesse
prendendo per il culo perfetto la parte
più bella è stata nella all'inizio
quella è stato bellissimo
matrix facciamo matrix ancora ancora
scrive ho vinto ho vinto cose slam bongo
lieve siamo questo che mi piace il nome
non ancora capito perché sto indossata
che io non l'ho toccato a zio ma c'è una
mira che è una merda giuro perché
piangere che abbia amico mio è solo un
tiro sbagliato giocata a mio zio non non
è normale
il portiere del secolo appena distanti
risultando ma che è stronzo
ma torniamo sul bottone anche più sicuro
questo è il fiore più bello più bello
che io abbia mai visto nella mia vita
monumenti per il design visto livello
veramente
[Musica]
mio dio
oh mio dio
[Musica]
qualcuno mi si studia chiasso livello
come lo ha fatto non lo so neanche io
speed challenge è una cosa cos'è make
the new world record
sono morto [ __ ] in salvo di aver
vinto ma niente bello se magari ci
stessi sopra il po chi cazzo fai steve
mi ha insistito ha preso assunto delle
droghe in questi giorni svolta mistica
puoi fare a farsi belle
io stento a capirlo quest'uomo guarda
che roba che cosa stai cos'è il quadro
umano si può fare un signore spingo gli
arpioni con la testa giusta il prossimo
al 90 per cento facciamo questo che
cos'è eccolo mi piace lo faccio solo
fatta dai dai
[ __ ] devo capire da ciò che ha del
salame quando parte sto livello 1 capito
perché
bello bello io c'ho la mira nel cuore ci
siamo ma che bello io non ci posso
credere che lo ma questo è ciò azzeccato
in pieno
[Musica]
ma seriamente
io sono stato tre ore a cercare gli
entra visto cazzo di buco qua e poi ce
l'ho fatta
ok vabbè basta ho capito questo livello
sta diventando strano se skype hughes lo
facciamo questo che mi sembra carino
io devo scappare dalla polizia con eddy
perché di checa 6 rubate no devo
riuscire a schivare con lo schifo
sì sì o presso i coltelli con le gambe
che è uno sport questo lo faccio spesso
machete tronic due addirittura al 2 è un
fatto che cos'è questa roba perché ci
sono dei machete
vabbè lasciamo perdere mira è che cazzo
però se ok adesso ciò due spade per
farne fuori 14 ho detto come possibile
come è possibile nella vita che ho vinto
io non lo so sword e 37 ma sono anche
questo perché quello che i machete
io sono un fenomeno che minaccia di duke
che cazzo fai posso tipo prenderti
lanciarti a quelli dietro così chi è che
vogliono gli ultimi vabbè lasciamo
questo è vero amore non c'è dubbio la
spada me la ridà hai visto che tipo
bravo no spam
bastardo serve mi serve la sbaglia non
si sa bene muoveva affanculo i muri non
è che posso stare qua tutto il giorno
attacca attaccato alla spada di un tizio
o ucciso hitler perché il paese di new
che adesso si scopre che i giustamente
manca l'elfo
[Musica]
non mi fa schifo mi sembrano ormai
niente niente quel cazzo di mattone
riuscita a perdere perché c'era un matto
vi rendete conto dello dello schifo
perfetto la bambina offrendo c'ero quasi
alla gente li ho più va bene se ti
lancio ma anche lo stile perfetto e
abbiati è stata la cosa più bella mai
fatta tanto sono stato schiacciato cenni
osservavano svelta cli car
c'è un prima che user weil che cazzo è
stato sì va bene ma ho visto veramente
roba che non ci sarei mai riuscito nella
vita ho vinto adesso si no cazzo non mi
annunci c'erano quattro bombe qua dentro
è riuscito a non morire non è possibile
questa cosa nella vita proprio prova
bene salvai l'oggetto e cos'è sta roba
anche ma perché devo lanciare quel qual
è il senso di sto livello ragazzi
l'altro gli esplode la faccia ma sta
violenza vorrei farlo perché non devo
morire agazzi ce la posso fare io
io ho un ananas [ __ ] va bene ci ho
provato
1 per cento possible facciamo questo va
che mi sembra ispi mi mi ispira cos'è oh
mio dio che è calmi che provoco nonno
ciò che mi sembra abbastanza in gamba
ok non perdere la tua testa micro mia ma
sai con chi stai parlando
abbiamo un mio dio che cazzo ma c'è una
patata al posto del collo stati scrivi
oldman il vecchio uomo è raccapricciante
va bene proviamo a far questo ma questo
questo non lo shock con una busta in
testa ma che cazzo stai facendo non
abbia pietà perché ti sei messo in un
sacchetto intesa halloween è passato da
un mese un altro po come se io devo
devono spaventare la gente ma cazzo mi
ami è sparito la maschera va bene farò
senza tanto se sei brutto lo stesso mi
fai paura ecco vedi che scappano uguale
ragazzi non fare un cazzo della maschera
non è brutto uguale evidente che salto
ha fatto babbo natale
d'accordo gli symbol trovo facciamo
questo mi sembra buono anche se non è da
un pezzo è che non faccio boltro quindi
non sono anche ho perso un po di skill
non ho perso un cazzo stavo dicendo per
lo stavo dicendo per distrarvi per farvi
credere che non ero più bravo ma non è
così vogliamo un'altra volta giusto
prevedere curiosità è perfetto che
allora niente io i miei baffi vinciamo
tutto most dangerous terzo cioè vale
niente delle scale più pericolose del
mondo cioè un arcobaleno qua ci vanno i
bambini però va bene
eccolo forzare forse non i bambini però
ci possiamo lavorare luca dato si no
ci ho provato per un mio addio alla
ragazzina che cazzo fai io non mi puoi
abbandonare così lurido bambino ecco
bravo visto chi è in vantaggio ad esso
extras shiver o mentre dormi vieni a
prendere il tuo padre si perfetto
servivo sono ancora vivo tra l'altro non
so come prova bene vai gambe vai gambe
forza gambiano devo spingervi o 100 per
cento impossible green pro questo è una
roba così bello ragazzi sparatevi questo
tutto per voi
come non detto fatto cosa che mi sono
saltate le gambe dopo va bene oddio cosa
come cazzo ha fatto arrivare qui e che
vittoria assurda che cos'è successo in
chat reining si vabbè ma questo neo
ninja training che cazzo ci fai luca
doni già training ecco infatti devo
andare bello perseveri ninja vanno così
in bici voi non lo sapete ma è così
table run
bellissimo il nome mi piace perché non
lo fa l'alcolizzato e mi chiedevo io non
mi farò battere da un alcolizzato
ok è un dio vabbè vai così eccoci
stronzo padre di dio che non ce la farei
intanto il mio tavolo è più bello del
tuo
ecco infatti visto ho vinto ha vinto ha
vinto ed uno share che ha perso la
bottiglia per ora quando accordo ragazzi
fatevi provare un paio di livelli come
al solito perché hanno fatto per me tipo
questo fa vige il 99 per cento
impossible anche se favi prova a fare
questo amico mio io non è che ci prova
faresti così io ce la faccio è diverso
deve capirlo
sinceramente non l'avevo vista la parola
demolizione ma va bene così ragazzi ho
un'idea che non so quanto possa
funzionare però ci provo
non è questa l'idea piano piano
ecco ciò fa eco sia bomba a fondare va
beh non si può fare agazzi non si può fa
avrei vinto se fosse stato possibile
fini questo livello ma non è possibile
perfetto ragazzi ho visto ho vinto vinto
almeno questa e vittoria nome pieno di
significato ragazzi quindi faccio questo
come ultimo perché mi sembra giusto
cos'è
ci sono delle bombe lo bello complimenti
e finito così il livello del secolo
senza dubbio d'accordo ragazzi concluso
qui perché è stata la puntata di happy
più strana nella storia però grazie per
questi livelli e pc o non ce la posso
più fare coltivati mi stanno provvedendo
e tra un po mi scavo anche il naso vieni
ragazzi servito è piaciuto come a setola
sull argomento vi piace anche la pagina
di facebook e come noi video trovate la
descrizione cioè se da prestiti
scheletri ci vediamo al prossimo video
bella ragazzi